[Music] what's up everyone three to watch
presented by Prine plus is back with the
first episode of 2024 and I'm your host Anna Dua
let's drop the puck in Tampa Bay as the LA Kings
come to town the kings are 44-2 in their last 10
while the lightning are 55-0 in the same span last
season Tampa was 1- one in two games against La
scoring seven goals and allowing six so expect
this one to go down to the wire and La ranks
12th in the NHL in goals per game this season
while Tampa is 14 the Kings win the shot volume
competition as they are tied for the most while
the lightning are tied for 20th the big name
for the Kings is Adrien kempi who has six goals
and nine points in his past seven games kempi has
four shots on goal in three of his past four games
King's Captain an Kopitar has points in four of
his past five with five total in the span Nikita
kov can't stop won't stop for the lightning with
five goals and 10 points during his six game point
streak and defenseman Victor Hedman has points in
eight of his past 10 next up the Canucks wrap up
their New York Road Trip on Long Island against
the Islanders Vancouver continues to lead the NHL
in goals per game this season while the Isles have
lost three of their past four and are allowing the
11th most goals per game there are a lot of big
names in Van City but their productive third line
is flying under the radar so let's take a look
Teddy Bluer has three goals and 12 points in his
past 11 and his linemate Dakota Joshua has three
goals and seven points in his past seven okay I'm
going to give one shout out to a big name for the
knocks and that's Quinn Hughes the defenseman has
points in seven of his past eight games let's
not count out the Islanders just yet Bo Horvat
has been tearing it up with 25 points in his past
19 games which includes 11 goals on the back end
Noah Dobson has 2 22 points in that same span and
Allstar Matt barzal has seven points in his last
seven games our last game has the Boston Bruins
heading out to the desert for some mullet magic
Boston is tied for the second most points in the
entire league and it seems like everyone on this
team is finding their name on the score sheet
Trent Frederick has been lighting lamps left
right and center with goals in three of his
past five and five total goals in that span
Charlie Coyle has points in seven straight and is
playing on the be second line with Jake debrusk
who has four goals and eight points during his
recent six-game point streak the Ys have been
struggling lately and are heading into this
matchup coming off three consecutive losses
if they hope to turn things around the pressure
falls on their Top Line play Keller leads the team
in points with 32 Nick schaltz ranks third on the
squad with 25 Center Alex kurera is getting the
shot to play between those two Wingers and has
points in three of his past four that's three
to watch from tonight's 10 game slate I'll see
you back here next week for another set of key
matchups